PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Cat-Out has
concluded that their packaging
subscriber is going to receive
a large number of messages.
Stay tuned to find out when
and how using pub subscribers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So far in the series, we
learned about Cloud Pub/Sub,
how it works using Cat-Out's
asynchronous order processing
service.
We saw how pub/sub helps manage
the interactions between order,
packaging, shipping, and
notification services.
In the last episode, we learned
that pub/sub supports both
push and pull message delivery.
Let's do a quick recap.
Push delivery
requires the client
to be a public HTTPS endpoint.
If you don't have
one, which means
your service is private
or firewalls are involved,
then you would use pull.
Pull is also more efficient
and minimizes latency.
So if events are
generated at, say,
100 or 1,000
requests per second,
then pull is your friend.
So today, let's focus
on Cat-Out's services
to learn pull subscribers.
Let's say it is the
high season for Cat-Out.
Lots of people are ordering
pretty cat posters,
which means the
packaging service needs
to process this huge
traffic with high efficiency
and low latency.
And we also know that the
packaging service is internal
and does not have a
public HTTPS endpoint.
Given these conditions--
large requests
per second, low
latency requirements,
and no public HTTPS endpoint--
the best way to setup
our packaging subscriber
is in pull mode.
The pub/sub service offers two
APIs for retrieving messages
in pull mode.
There's a pull API and there
is a streaming pull API.
The default is
the streaming pull
API, which is the
most effective way
to achieve high-volume
processing asynchronously.
And for this reason,
default client libraries
just use streaming pull for
maximum throughput and lowest
latency.
Streaming pull is
actually a lot like push,
in that it allows pub/sub to
push messages to the client
as they become available.
The difference here
is that the client
gets to initiate this
bidirectional persistent
connection.
The protocol here is
also a lot more efficient
than HTTP POST used by push.
Cat-Out's packaging
service requires
high-volume processing.
And the best way to achieve
high-volume processing
is by processing asynchronously.
So packaging servers should just
use default client libraries
that use streaming
pull API and offers
maximum throughput
and low latency.
Now that we know how a message
is received by pull subscriber,
let's double-click on
the message itself.
The messages sent
by the publisher
can contain custom attributes.
And in subscriber
code, you will have
to process those attributes.
In Cat-Out's case, say we
are sending the message
from order service to
packaging subscriber.
There would be custom
message attributes
to include, like user_id,
city, and poster_id.
Let's see how to
send and receive
these message attributes.
We will use the same quick start
code we used in episode three.
If you've not seen
it, now is the time
to check it out, and
then continue on here.
We are in our Python
quickstart folder.
Let's open pub.py.
In the pub method,
we will add the logic
to update the message
to include custom
attributes-- the user_id,
city, and poster_id.
Then we open two terminals to
start our packaging subscriber
in one and send the order
message from the order
publisher in the other.
And we see that the message
with the same message ID
is received by the
packaging subscriber
with the custom
attributes that were sent.
Now what if suddenly,
Cat-Out becomes famous
and their order rate
increases rapidly?
Since messages are being
published at a higher rate
than they are being
consumed, they
would have to be
processed fast enough.
If this situation
persists, then Cat-Out
should consider increasing the
number of subscriber client
instances to process the
requests in parallel.
But if this is a transient
spike in messages,
say, due to Black Friday or
more cat birthdays in a month,
then there could be
a few possibilities.
It's possible that one
client could have a backlog
of messages, but another client
in the network has capacity,
but this free client cannot
process those messages
because the first client
maintains a lease on them.
It's also possible that the
client libraries repeatedly
extend the
acknowledgment deadline
for backlogged messages.
Those messages continue
to consume memory, CPU,
and bandwidth resources.
And eventually, the subscriber
runs out of those resources.
To mitigate these
issues, you need
to use the flow control
feature of the subscriber.
In this Python example, we
are limiting the subscriber
to only have 10 outstanding
messages at a time.
In the high-volume
context, it is
important to mention
that the subscriber also
support concurrency depending
on the programming language.
For language implementations
that support parallel threads,
such as Java and Go,
the client libraries
make a default choice for
the number of threads,
but this choice may not be
optimal for your application.
If you find that your subscriber
application is not keeping up
with the incoming message
volume, but is not CPU bound,
you should increase
the thread count.
And for CPU-intensive message
processing operations,
reducing the number of
threads might be appropriate.
Now, there could be times when
you see duplicate messages
from pub/sub.
This usually happens when
you acknowledge a message
before it's acknowledgment
deadline has expired.
So pub/sub resends the
message, leading to duplicates.
You can detect this
behavior in Stackdriver
by monitoring the acknowledge
operations with the expired
response code.
To reduce the duplication rate,
extend the message deadline.
Some client libraries
handle this automatically,
but if you are building
your own client library,
then use
modifyAckDeadline method
to extend it the
acknowledgment deadline.
On the other hand,
if you want to force
pub/sub to retry a message, just
set modifyAckDeadline to zero.
Now, there are cases
where you might
need to do a bit more
work than just using
the asynchronous client library
we've been talking about
so far.
In those cases, you would
use the synchronous pull API.
It's recommended to use
synchronous pull when
the application logic might
rely on a polling pattern
to retrieve messages
or your application
requires a precise
cap on the number
of messages retrieved by it.
Streaming pull at the
moment can overdeliver
before it settles
down, so when you
have a spiky load of
very small messages,
it can get you in trouble.
Those applications are better
off using synchronous pull.
Or in the third case, if you're
using a language framework,
like PHP for example,
that does not
support gRPC and
require HTTP REST API,
then you have no choice but
to use synchronous pull.
If we focus our attention
on our Cat-Out application,
due to some resource
constraints,
the notification service is
designed so it can receive
a batch of messages in a single
HTTP request and the number
of messages cannot
exceed, say, 10.
Based on what we
just learned, Cat-Out
should use synchronous pull
API in this specific scenario.
All right, so today,
we learned how
to receive messages
using pull method.
We looked at message
flow control,
concurrency, streaming
pull API, and dealing
with duplicate messages.
Join us next time as we
take on the next topic,
receiving messages using push.
Until then, give us
a like, subscribe,
and let us know what you want
to learn about Cloud Pub/Sub.
[MUSIC PLAYING]